Well, let's see.
Hidden in these two
statements are two rates.
The first compares 448
miles to seven hours, and
the other compares 496
miles to eight hours.
And we want to see which of these rates,
which of these speeds, is higher.
So we're going to convert
them to a unit rate.
So, let's see.
For Rafael,
he went 448 miles in seven hours,
448 is actually just seven times 64.
So I have this, over this,
and notice the common factor.
So we simplify, and this gives me
a unit rate of 64 miles over one hour.
So again,
he was going 64 miles per hour.
We can do the same thing for
Anastasia, and I notice that 496,
is just eight times 62,
I see there's a common factor, and so
written as a unit rate,
Anastasia's speed is 62 miles per hour.
64, once again, is bigger than 62,
so Raphael went faster.
Even though Anastasia went farther,
496 versus 448 miles,
it took her an hour longer.
To calculate their speeds,
I had to calculate a unit rate.